next speaker is K series he's based at
the University of California where he is
a professor of design and media arts
particularly known for his mural art
which is derived from initially hand
drawing and then scripted software
processes which seem to never give
totally predictable ways in which the
final product is going to come out he's
shown his work widely here and all over
the world his talk is called conditional
drawing ok thank you very much it's very
good to be here today so in my mind
drawings a way of thinking and exploring
it's not tied to a specific media more
specific material so with that we'll dig
in this presentation could also be
called drawing with code I'm kind of a
double evil presenter today not only do
I use computers I actually program them
myself I like to think of code
computation computers as a subset of a
larger larger theme larger topic that I
find more interesting which is working
in systems working in patterns and
working with instructions so we're have
five topics today the first ones ideas
so now we're 1965 we're in Stuttgart
Freder not gay the creator of this
Potter drawing is a mathematic student
he's one of the very first people one of
the three people in the world to produce
Potter drawings with aesthetic intent
rather than to produce engineering
drawing in this particular drawing there
are a lot of random values being used so
here's a rhetorical question in 1965 why
are random values a core component of
software and computing machines
computing machines are for accuracy for
speed for clarity so the position and
location and the density and the in the
pen use for each one of these hatches
was determined by random operations this
is the computer this is the computer
operator sitting in his temperature
isolated booth in this case feeder knock
a who wrote the wrote the software these
sort of the aesthetic protagonist in the
story has no contact with the actual
machine this is the front panel this is
the back panel here you can see all the
soldered hand soldered connections all
the vacuum tubes that perform the logic
these are the tape drives which store
the information and this is what gets
spit out of the computer this is the
paper tape which is fed into the zoo's
graph of Matt Z 64 is it two-ton to
access plotting machine here you can see
it drawing the pin can go up and down
many different types of materials can be
placed inside having said a little bit
about the machine and now need to say
that I don't care about the machine
really at all and what I'm interested in
is the logical process in the system
that the artist in this case is is
writing in order to control that machine
so here we have an image of freedom naki
doing the work i'm interested in he's
writing the program in this case he's
doing it with paper and pencil as a
series of logical diagrams so now we
move back to nineteen thirteen we have
Marcel Duchamp I think many of you know
this work the basic idea is you take a
piece of string that's one meter long
and from one meter high you drop it onto
the ground and then fix it there that
then becomes the standard units that
Duchamp uses in later work I'm
interested this is a critique of
standards and critique of units of
measurement but more importantly as a
tool so the shop built his own tool its
own instead of drawing sort of templates
that he used to produce further drawings
so here we have a piece from nineteen
fourteen and then here it was integrated
into the large glass these areas here
were produced by the the stoppage curves
so moving forward in time 1963 I haven't
saw the land in the sketch pad system
this was at MIT so here we see
Sutherland sitting at his machine
drawing this in my opinion is the most
interesting early cad system it was
direct manipulation with the light pen
and although it was an oscilloscope
screen that was blinking and really low
resolution he was able to draw in
geometry on an infinite canvas he was
able to zoom in scale and produce work
make templates that thing can be
reproduced within the system like pens
at that time were a dominant
way of interact with machine was more
direct than the indirect mouse and
keyboard and I think what I'm most
interested in about sketch pad is the
way it combines the sort of technical
precision needed for technical drawing
with the natural motions of man are
idiosyncrasies where etc so here you can
see for example the drawing that was
done by the person with the light pen
you can see the result there so we're
able to take a mark an organic mark and
then produce a fine sort of perfect
geometry line from that I'm more
interested in the not the fine lines but
I think this is an interesting hybrid
system all right now 1958 we have John
tangley making is meta Matic drawing
machines here's the artist himself with
one of those machines this one is
powered by bicycle what I think's really
interesting about these machines is we
think about the 1950s we think about
computers we think about order we think
about centralization of power we think
about clarity and precision jean tangley
is doing the exact opposite he's using
motors he's using mechanisms to create
chaos disorder and I think in many ways
a more interesting statement as an
artist sort of against the movement of
the sort of technocratic Society all
right now 1967 we have logo logo was an
extraordinary system here we have a
plotter that's unconstrained it's free
free range plotter it also has a pin
that moves up and down and logo had its
most sort of important impact when it
moved to the home computer environment
so in here we can see the robot this
extraordinary drawing device has been
turned into a few pixels of a triangle
which you see here what's interesting
about logo is the way it defines drawing
so in logo is a system really made for
children to develop an understanding of
geometry we remove the Cartesian grid so
you don't draw a line from coordinate
2030 to coordinate 80-100 you are the
system that's drawing so you draw
relative to yourself this is something
that maps to a more natural mindset so I
walk forward 100 steps I turnright 120
degrees I walk forward 100 steps again
and that performs a triangle so this
other way of thinking about geometry
which is centered in the individual i
think is what sixth orient their also
putting that into a its syntax which is
also very straightforward to allow
people to draw using software all right
Sol LeWitt wall drawings 1968 through
2007 what I'm interested in with Lou it
is the way that the drawing is encoded
as a piece of English text rather than
computer code that then is executed by a
draftsperson first baile Witten later by
a draft person so if you look at wall
drawing 325 we see on a black wall white
horizontal lines to straight one crayon
one would too not straight when crayon
one rope two lines are equally spaced so
we have this this notation which is
ambiguous there's many ways this can be
executed and performed almost like a
score this is an example of one of the
Wits drawings I think you're probably
familiar with them what I'm interested
in is this process with the wit even
Loney had drafts draft people producing
these drawings they would go through a
series of sketches they'd confer with
fluid and then they would actually then
produce the work so there's this
interpretation of the text two different
kinds of sketches to a final decision
and for me what's really fascinating
about little bit is we have this short
piece of text maybe five sentences or so
then that gets translated into a week of
work for a team of people doing
back-breaking work on a wall and this
this gap between the idea and the
execution for me is really fascinating
if I were going to talk longer about
this topic I talked about Manford more I
talked about Vera molenaar and I talked
about Harold Cohen but I'm going to push
on for now all right next topic is coded
form I'm going to do something dangerous
i'm going to do live programming all
right so about 10 years ago Ben Frey and
I developed this programming environment
called processing and we did it because
we wanted a better way to do our own
work and also a better way to teach
students I've been teaching now for
around a decade and when we draw a line
in processing we draw a line like this
we say line and then we're back to our
coordinate system and then we hit run
then that line is then rendered within
the the window or the frame that we just
built so if we want to extend it into
areas which I think are more interesting
in software dynamic systems
or interaction we add a little bit more
structure so we say void setup we give
it a size which is a little bit larger
than 100 pixels that's really
constrained we say void draw and the
code inside draw runs continuously until
the program stopped I'm going to give it
a relative coordinate so i'm going to
say mount or whoops with / 2 + height /
2 for the start of the line and then
Mouse x for the ending point and mouse
why for the ending point of the y
coordinate and then I'm going to run the
program then you'll see now we have a
system really simple system for drawing
and I just draws a line to wherever I
choose to position the line with the
cursor and sort of that's that's how I
draw I draw in this way by sort of
encoding my visual ideas into this form
of a computer language in this case
built on Java this is a different
technique for for programming education
design education in a few ways one
because it's indirect you're not
actually putting the line with your hand
or on screen you're defining it through
a notation and it's a radically
different way of pursuing sort of
computer programming education because
it's visual designers and artists can
within a few hours start to make drawing
is that they they find exciting rather
than spending months doing tech space
and mathematical based assignments so
when computers started to be used for
drawing in the mid-1960s accuracy
precision these are things that of
course come to the front my own personal
interest in using the computer to draw
is drawing systems that allow for the
phenomena of emergence so this is a
piece by Jared Tarbell called substrate
I'm just going to run this whoops
so the process that is following can be
really simply explained basically draw a
line and keep drawing that straight line
until you hit an edge or another line
when you hit an edge you then spawned
two new lines that are perpendicular to
yourself on either side so through this
very short instruction very concise we
see something that is intricate begin to
emerge from that so this is the property
of software that I've been exploring and
the one that I'm going to now move into
discussing micro image this is a series
of drawings that I did it I started
about ten years ago to me they look
primitive now but I think they're still
interesting to show and they're based on
the work of Valentina Brayton Berg
Valentina Brayton Berg's a
neuroanatomist and in 1984 he wrote this
really elegant short book called
vehicles which takes his his sort of
lifelong experience with neuroanatomy
and condenses it into a series of short
hypothetical machines so you can see
here from biology we have a sensor you
know for example an eye or or something
and connected to a motor here we have a
cross connection and we have a little
bit of both which is more what happens
in nature what we can see is if we start
adding in relationships for example here
we have a inverse relationship between
the sensor and the actuator and we have
a stimulus in the environment that this
wiring this this mechanism creates the
behavior I'm Brayton Berg called this
wiring aggressive and this one curious
this one approaches and moves away this
one basically attacks so let's look at
some software again so this is a diagram
based on Brayton Briggs vehicles and
it's kind of the simplest first thing to
do and this is the first thing i did a
day after after reading the book i was
curious to see what would happen if I if
I made a simulation of these different
vehicles and here they're color-coded
the different colors represent different
wirings you see when i add more into the
situation how over time they start with
an even distribution and then they
aggregate together and by changing the
parameters of each one for example how
far the sensors are from each other or
what the relationship between the sensor
and sort
little simulated actuator is we get many
different kinds of behaviors you can
even add a little bit of jitter which
creates a more organic motion and as I
was doing this what i thought was more
interesting than the position of these
individual elements these little
machines was the past that they took
over time so for example now we're
looking at lines that are just the
history of the its positions strung
together into a single linear element so
from there I started doing work that I
consider to be more more visually
interesting and as these were the path
prints which we see here these tissue
prints and when I was producing these
images they were done in a real-time way
so these machines are moving on screen
and I'm moving around the elements I'm
pushing and pulling them where I want
them to be I'm choreographing them as
it's running and I'm in control at two
levels on control of the individual
behaviors of the small machines and also
in the environment itself this is an
enlargement this is another print from
the same series you can see here how
they're exhibited each row here is one
parameter set and then basically I'm
mapping some of the possible space made
with each parameter set lately as
printing technology has been enhanced
I'm able to start producing his larger
scale and then at this point I shifted
and moved away from the real time so I
think as you know if you're working with
software you're working 30 to 60 frames
a second you're limited in the number of
elements you can work with so in that
case I was drawing 2000 around with two
thousand machines at a time each one had
line lengths of up to 200 so I'm drawing
many thousands of lines a second and
moved away from real time and moved to
rendering and then now i'm working with
half a million lines and you can see
that it gives the quality of the image a
very distinct feeling it's less about
linearity more about massing you can see
an enlargement there and again these
colors are color-coded based on the
wiring of the vehicles so red is one
wiring blues and other wiring etc
removing color in order to see the the
core and then here's a photograph of one
of the actual print so you can see a
little bit
of the material of the object rather
than the simulation of it of course is
still being simulated alright next
process compendium so in working with
emergence I started developing things in
this way doing these kinds of pieces of
software and from here I started i
arrived at those forms through doing
through doing what i call sketching in
code so let's look at that the idea of
sketching in code is that you you work
through ideas in a way you first sketch
by hand and then and then move over into
this representation because there's
things you can do and see in code that
you just can't with a pencil sketch or
drawing so here the basic premise was
let's make two shapes that know about
their boundaries and they move away from
each other when they when they overlap
so next was putting more into the
environment just to prove that it worked
it scaled up next was to give each one
of these circles of behavior that they
moved along a straight line but when
they touched another element they
started rotating and so this this
diagram I wasn't able to see that and so
I did a next diagram where I was able to
add in visual information so I could see
better what was happening inside the
machine so the yellow dot he represents
the orientation you can see when they're
overlapping with another element they
begin spinning and then so from there I
started removing information in this
case I'm I've removed the circumference
of the circle and I've started added
something else I've added a line when
the two circles are touching you draw a
line between their Center points so in
my mind this is this is a process kind
of analogous to doing continuous
sketches by hand and refining ideas but
it's done in a different medium now I've
removed everything but the lines and
they're white or black depending on
their length and then so that led to
this experiment we're here I'm
positioning them in different
orientations so there I was positioning
the circles around the circumference of
another circle i'm here from from a line
and then because they have this property
that they move away from the other
elements they push themselves out so
starting with these are different
initial conditions
able to cause different different
drawings to grow so here again I'm
looking at the orientation of the
element rather than the lines between
them and so that's that's a process that
I follow in doing all this work so that
led to the this work which is I call the
process compendium and it's based on a
series of geometry and a series of
behaviors so circle is my starting point
with geometry we move it in a straight
line we constrained a surface we change
direction while touching another element
and we move away from the overlapping
elements so that's the work before but
now describe more clearly and plainly
here we have element 1 which is an
aggregate of form 1 plus behaviors 1
through 4 and then here we have the
diagram we were looking at before but
it's a little more clear we can see the
orientation we can see the rotation as
they touch another element we can see
moving away from the other elements but
then of course now that this is encoded
as text simple English instructions that
everybody can read it and understand we
can interpret in different ways we can
start with different parameters and see
how the system unfolds according to the
new parameter set again these are
diagrams all right so we have element 1
and then we have element 5 element 5
uses a line as its core geometry and has
two new behaviors orient toward the
direction of the element that it's
touching and deviate from the current
direction
so over time they begin to aggregate
together as they assume or average their
orientations this is the full library
that I have at this point is very
minimal very constrained but I'm able
capable of doing a lot with it it's kind
of the property of this some this
process so then i define it as another
piece of English text which defines how
its imaged draw a line from the center
of elements that are touching set the
value of the shortest possible line to
black and the longest to white with
varying grades representing values in
between so this is the software that is
processed for I'm going to let this run
for a few seconds so it begins at
maximum entropy everything is randomly
distributed and over time order begins
to emerge as the behaviors are followed
so this is process 18 it's based on
element 5 which were the lines we were
looking at a moment ago it says draw a
quadrilateral connecting the end points
of each pair of elements that are
touching and increase the opacity of the
quadrilateral why the elements are
touching and decreasing while they are
not so again starting an entropy and
then order begins to emerge but I when I
exhibit this work to the public I show
the side by side I show the element and
then the process and then the
instructions on the left and right so
for me it's really about the process
it's about the diagram and what the
diagram produces and here you can see a
version of process 18 that's presented
in that way where both sides are the
same thing one is an instantaneous view
the other is the aggregate view over
time of drawing these quadrilaterals on
top of one another all right so from
that I didn't produce a group of
additional work sort of on top of that
if I think of that as my core basic
research so this is a enlargement of a
print from process for this is a print
from process for that shows different
ways that it grows over time so give an
initial starting configuration it grows
into each one of these different forms
here's a 2 projection of process for and
this is a performance which is literally
drawing so I'm on stage with the largest
Wacom that I can find and I'm drawing as
the music is performed this is
steve reich's music for 18 musicians
highly percussive phasing rhythmic piece
and essentially i broke the piece down
into a different series of graphic
language and then i'm writing these
marks on to the screen sort of in time
with the music and following a conductor
but then once these individual elements
are on-screen they follow their
behaviors autonomously so it's more of
my my marks the way I draw with the the
machines following their behavior this
is an installation again based on
process for each one of these discs is
an autonomous software process in
constant motion and these are prints
based on process 18 so when things move
from software from real time into into
into print they changed greatly because
I have more resolution I have more
resolution in space and more resolution
in time these are some simple mills
using the exact exact same data and
these are some dip tix also based on
process 18 and for me this is the most
interesting image because it shows the
material of the drawing itself alright
lastly we have chronograph so this is
the project of mine that has the most to
do with architecture and the lease to do
with drawing but it has a lot to do with
collage and so I think of collage the
same way I think of drawing it's a way
of quickly iterating ideas it's a way of
thinking and a way of sort of putting
things into physical space so they can
be discussed with colleagues so this
projects our colleague is a
collaboration with Hal roesner and this
was a commission for the new world
centre which was designed by Gary
partners it opened about one year ago in
Miami Florida you can see a little bit
more the context and there you can read
that one clearly and so into produced
this project we took photographs of the
building over the two and a half years
that it was being built and we produced
thousands of collages and from those
thousands of collages which you see here
some of them we made 365 different
compositions and the point of this
project was to have a marriage between
architecture and music so bringing
rhythm and flow and pattern in time
using architecture as the core base
visual element
and so the 365 compositions each one is
displayed on the wall for one hour and
then at the end of the hour there's a
transition where it iterates through a
series of splices of other compositions
and then lands on the composition that
will be live for the for the next hour
and in doing so we are basically
excavating forms that were captured
while the building was being constructed
and then representing back onto the
surface for me it was a pleasure being
in this building on and off while I was
being built and finding these forms and
being able to present them back because
I think in many cases they're they're
fascinating forms that are entirely
disguised as the the final layer surface
gets put onto it and so this is one of
the compositions this is how this is the
individual element that makes up that
composition and there's a lot of
software and logic behind that and again
we went through a sketching process of
writing software simply iterating
improving and then we ended up with this
a really simple data format where we
parameterised everything and basically
we set out on the wall and in front of
the building for a few nights tweaking
these values by one hundredths in order
to make it work to tune it within the
context of this four-story projection
within this public park so am i over on
time all right I'll just show this up
I'll show the software quickly so this
is a representation of the software and
you can see the the quality of the
motion it's meant to be an ambient
display of course when it's four stories
high it tracks more attention than now
and also it's really suited for that
space I'm the forms echo forms of the
building itself and the the Art Deco
neighborhood around and so in a way it
echoes that I'm going to iterate through
some of the different compositions and
it's not meant to be cinematic it's not
meant to hold your attention but to
become a part of that space to activate
it at night
and so it's also meant to be a clock as
well so a little bit of energy is put
into it every second and that energy
dissipates over the course of the second
actions happen on the minute and then
the largest action happens on the hour
which you can see here basically marking
the time by the number of transitions
that it goes through so that's the end
of the presentation I don't have a grand
conclusion but I look forward to hashing
things out in the panel all right thank
you very much
alright I'm Michael Young like to thank
our five speakers these were some
incredibly insightful provocative and
entertaining presentations we have this
morning and thank you very much let's
see what we can do for a discussion we
have done by Quan so I'm going to be
very brief and then we're going to open
up to the audience I'm sure there's many
questions I would like to ask the one
thing though that I would like to maybe
offer for starting some discussion
amongst the panelists are I think if we
take face value this is drawing dead
question literally it's it's almost
rhetorical drawing is not going to die
it's been with us always we've always
made marks of some sort but uh and
whether or not those weren't sort of
done with graphite on paper or the
illumination of pixels in them cool down
a relationship there's still like there
are still mark so we're going to be able
to use to describe architectural
elements calculations officials
temperatures the question I think that
comes up from several of our panelists
here one that I think we do need to
think about and is a very interesting
arena for thought is maybe it's not
dying may be drawing is being moved from
a more central condition within the
architectural practice within the
architectural discourse and if that is
so then what is replacing it and I think
we'd have to say that maybe that is the
digital model in many ways the digital
model is becoming the core concern of
the majority of practices majority of
architectural students so then we need
to ask ourselves in terms of the
difference between a digital model and a
drawing are these differences minor
trivial are these differences radical
engage
and how we come to terms with that
really is my hope for a conference like
this my hope for what we can understand
and the changing nature of our
mediations how we can push things
forward how we can experiment with
issues at hand what does it mean to work
through computation we have somebody
like k series is showing us
computational work who I mean I have to
engage it on an aesthetic level it's
proposing absolutely traditional
beautiful lip incredibly new ways of
engaging things like the loss of edge or
intensity and density and visualization
of depthless Martin Chen's explanations
of how I see death sounds right into
that and with andrew its presentation
about the history of the mechanization
of drawing we see that this goes back
much further than just the 90s this has
been happening for decades if not
centuries and it's wonderful to see
wonderful to give us that contamination
of that history and I i think that uh
mr. Schumacher would probably say that
the digital model has made a fundamental
change and the question is and what can
we do how we talk about how do we begin
to argue with it in argue for and have a
little bit more questions for you but
maybe later and well I mean it's usually
try to be monitored as a moderator but
eventually in moderation is gonna come
sorry we'll just jump into it as muzzle
light the fire early and then we'll see
how it burns out it might burn out fast
and might continue a little longer I
think we need to have a conversation
about parametrics as architects I think
it's a fundamental we're all parametric
architects at a certain level and nerves
curve is a parametric entity this is
fundamental to what we do changes the
way we think about things and how we
interact with the environments the
digital environments that we design in
now in that the problem that I see and I
guess I'm moving right into a question
for you why do you have to present the
way that you're presenting it is it is
it's you seem very intelligent very
sensible and in some way I'm asking
myself thank you and i stitched us
together me to end up mateys you know
maybe it's my fault but I can't I stitch
together the argument why are you
presenting what is actually the kind of
opposite condition of house al-hadid
initially got brought to us which was
she was able to convince everybody
through her mediations she was able to
gather allies around her if we want to
talk about some of the other
connotations to social networking and
actor there and everything else you're
bringing up and then people made me very
critical about whether there was a
theoretical conceptual discourse to kind
of follow that up you're almost doing
the promising thing you're always trying
to give us the discourse without the
images and problems you have the images
you do I mean with
do you have more images than we could
possibly ever muster for the
strengthening of this argument and why
this is a specific concern for me is
because I think we do need to talk about
the parametric in whenever I bring it up
two things happen two things happen
instantaneously oh are you talking about
BIM are you talking about Patrick
Schumacher it's almost like the
conversation gets shut down right at
that moment and I mean thinking about
just some of the presentations we have
today about parametrics there's a whole
wild and wonderful world that we should
be engaging now not now I can't change
you in the way you want to present your
discourse but there must be something
must be some other way to begin to drive
this conversation in architecture in
order to not shut it down right but
engage more and more people engage more
and more disciplines so I know that that
second part is more comments and not a
question but how you could understand it
now is specifically if if you could
formulate for me at least how you
understand the major differences with
the digital model from the drawing
medium as it existed before and how that
then begins to provide new opportunities
for us as architects to think represent
mediate convince the world that our
ideas are well
first of all I mean it's true that I
feel that my presentation failed a
number of levels this man but then I
think Casey stepped in and made some
great demonstrations where you can see
the just the handsome of the capacity to
build up what i would call rich complex
environments and that's I think what we
need we need to increase the complexity
of the build environment because our
society is more diverse more
differentiated more complex richer and
to build up these environments with more
variables with more concerned with more
constraints and demands we need these
new tools and I think the we can no
longer rely on a handful of platonic
geometric shapes which we compose we
could we can track on a piece of paper
and build up as a handful of figures
kind of collected and called composition
we need to we need to have more aspects
constraining the build-up and but we
also need to proliferate the ontology
repertoire of primitives and aspects so
we're talking about gradients we're
talking about much more layered and
dense environments and we're talking
about drawing more affiliations and
connections and letting elements
resonate with each other represent each
other affiliate with each other and for
that we we developed a tool of course as
a congeniality between what we start to
desire and what we can do I mean we
always finding that the tools gives us
an clues about what we get want to
achieve so there's a dialectic and they
look back added after kind of 20 years
of cumulative engagement with with the
new potential new tools it the space
pervades and the difference of results I
find quite striking but ultimately
I find it liberating and fascinating to
work with nearly will become
self-organizing systems that you use
sketch with scripts through series and
three series and I think processing is a
great tool which this which we exploring
in particular academic environment and
not only the kind of endless builder of
element open element but the kind of
interactive interconnected
self-organizing formal systems
multi-layered and multi ontology system
signified and that's where I find the
key striking difference and that of
course that this also connects with the
parallel build-up of production
capacities and the translation capacity
of these explorative side of things is
also extremely important so so it is on
the one hand you have a kind of
explorative digital sketching which
replaces the certain extent the hand
sketching bands getting through the
interacts with that and then on the
other hand we have the world of making
this precise making the technological
fees were making that into really
sophisticated a product on these two
planes I think we've gone quite fine
simply the superiority of these of the
total media can apply for me as striking
and and that's why I think what what is
left behind is perhaps all the versions
of often trying to do that and these
older versions simply cannot compete are
all the mics on yeah otherwise
regardless I think for me one of the
things that Patrick is getting at it I
think might come to the question about
the relationship between model and
drawing is really in a particular sense
the question of the combinatorial the
question of combinatorial generation
specifically
and I think that's one thing that's been
with this sort of parametric approach
and some of the historical examples
really almost from the from the
beginning there's this aspiration it
through the combinatorial approach and
through the editing of that sort of
combinatorial generation of of
possibilities that there's one
possibility or a few possibilities that
will perfectly suit the design problem
which i think is a totally distinct
project from where the drawing comes
from historically with a great deal of
intentionality a great deal of as as
we've learned it a sense of self of
decision and I think that's I think
there's some fundamental tension there
in a fundamental question about whether
this sort of parametric approach in and
of itself requires or prescribes that
sort of that sort of combinatorial
interest and actually myself bits of its
skeptical of it because the process of I
don't know the process of genetic
innovation in that sort of code seems so
ill-suited to the intentionality of a
specific mode mode of experience right
but I don't know it's I don't know if
it's possible I mean I think it's the
aesthetic results are phenomenal right
but are those architectural results I
don't know eventually door so you should
step in you that you're not in your head
I think one of the things you're trying
to get doctors find that intentionality
all the way into a further state of
digital yeah and I would agree with
Andrew that it's kind of bizarre to
think that you know genetic algorithms
could be used to generate architectural
form and it's funny when you look at
various modeling systems that generate
form and you see someone sort of pick a
foreman if you know something about
where that technology came from it just
seems very bizarre but I think what
could be interesting is if one starts to
generate a form with sketching sort of
traditional sketching that then one
could perhaps look to a body of
techniques that meant might try to fit
a range of shapes to that sketch but not
in a rigid way in a way that would kind
of establish a dialogue I think that
could be pretty interesting I think
there's done it yeah there's some aspect
of combinatorial inflection once the
decision is made and the trajectory is
taken that maybe is the way to inform
that to full download it back in okay
like we should open it to some audience
questions do we have some one writer eat
the Sun is a very good I have a question
I guess first for Patrick and maybe you
can bring Marvin in Patrick you used a
simile of comparing architecture to the
economy and currency to drawing and form
with the end of the economy the function
of currency is based on its the known
value of it and it's finite amount with
the explosion of drawings and form at
what point do we reach v mire Germany in
1932 I think that's a very interesting
you put your finger on an interesting
aspect of this analogy which is the
danger of inflation with with with these
specialized success media so you have a
danger of conflation of course in
in the money medium when price and value
diverge and you lose trust and sense
communication breaks down and then we
have to kind of regress into kind of
more primitive forms of communication
and the same thing I would say is a
permanent danger with respect to the the
medium of the drawing which we initially
need to project forward and convince and
bring people on board and have the
audacity come to communicate radical
innovations and make them compelling and
and draw kind of investors behind it but
there's of course also the dangers over
stretch as the sd's medium proliferate
media proliferate and are used and
abused to create visions and and ideas
and prospects regional that could have
had largely illusory and maybe not so
easily distinguished at first glance by
by the audience need to control and
bring aboard then you have also the
inflationary tendency and the kind of
loss of trust and disintegration
potentially of that of that authority of
the design and architects and you found
those i'm looking at peter cook you
found kind of in the you know in the
exuberance of a kind of explorative
drawing in the in the in the in the late
60s 70s into these kind of ideas of of
modular mega cities and and and walking
cities and mega structures there was the
kind of sense that was so easy in terms
of the technique of drawing if you had
the mode of translation to sketch out a
diagram and proliferate the diagram and
and and project linear cities the linear
city spanning the whole equator of
course there is this moment of the
potential of over stretch and
and inflation and the same dangers of
course exists today when we have when we
have on the one hand a wonderful
proliferation of an exploratory domain
at the same time the potential of an
inflationary collapse of the currency of
contemporary digital drawing so that
inflationary collapse is catalyzed by
the homogeneity of a product is that
also the lack of meaning full feasible
rational underpinning of these animal
just a brief follow-up the reason I
mentioned Marvin is do we have
perceptually a limited number of things
that we can perceive coherently
absolutely i was about to add in that
the analogy works extremely well for
understanding information processing in
the brain one of the most basic
principles of brain operation is that
it's limited in capacity our heads are
not going to get bigger and neurons fire
at a certain speed 0 at any given time
people are only able to track up to
three or four objects and that's why I
was able to make you all blind to the
gorilla because once you get over four
objects people its ability to track more
just drops and you know more people can
you can try to chunk more information
into that for but the number is four and
any number beyond one is actually a
decrement so I think you always have to
keep that in mind and inflation the need
for economy is a very good principle but
people can also read fields to like not
tracking individual object and you can
see differences in fields and pattern
matching and that's right textures feels
those can be treated by the visual
system as one object or at least leave
it counts as one unit of information and
so you can extract more information from
the statistics or the summary statistics
of a broader image but still there are
limitations in the detail there as well
you'll be my question is for Julie
Dorsey I'm Cooper from Carnegie Mellon
I'm so impressed by the way you're able
to take free hand drawing is
into a three-dimensional framework so
that we can move through it what I'm
curious about is have you looked at the
possibility of not treating these
sketches in strictly as a
two-dimensional way there's a very
interesting drawing teacher named chemo
nickel ladies from many many years ago
who handles drawing in a way that's very
sculptural it's almost non visual have
you tried using things that involve
pressure on the surface of the two
dimensional planes that you use not yet
but that's something that we're we've
talked about and I think are starting to
to implement so your question brings to
mind two things so right now the
canvases are our thin they we can use of
the pressure of a tablet to change the
stroke and so on but one would I think
like to have a thick canvas where you
could you know sort of have a planar
element that has many levels within it
terms of depth if you know simulating
different kinds of papers and opacities
and whatnot but I think what you make
what you really make me think about is a
kind of representation that might
include strokes and then something
normally people in computer vision which
is the kind of inverse of computer
graphics they want to recognize things
when they see something in a picture
they want to complete make complete
structure but I think there's actually
an interesting place between graphics
and vision which is that there's
something in between maybe a two and a
half D representation or the addition of
shadow that could give you a more an
enhanced perception of something again
being able to see more possibilities so
it's a great observation
time for one more question yeah I guess
this is probably directed a little bit
towards everyone one of the things that
was very striking in hearing the
presentations today was about
constraints and the absence of
constraints so it seems to me that we're
in a fairly unusual historical moment in
the lifting of constraints in terms of
how we draw and what we can build and
this practices of Gary and Hadid are
very emblematic of this and I guess what
interests me is the question of okay so
now now we can do all of this these
things but do it is it interesting to
actually think about introducing
constraints because if you look at
practically any architectural situation
in history you see that it's the play
against those resistant forces that
actually leads to invention and and real
a real kind of moments of breakthrough
so what's the push back now and if we
don't have push back do we put it in and
I think in this regard I think actually
Casey's talk was very interesting
because in your you are introducing
constraints in this very kind of simple
way you know there's a very limited
number of operations that you're
allowing them is the computer to do and
I think the results were really very
intriguing because you were showing the
myriad possibilities within those
restricted control parameters but I
think thinking about Gary and Hadees
practices I don't know what those
constraints are and anybody else coming
from outside the field I'm excited about
more ambitious and fantastic
architecture I think the constraint of
the body is the constraint that we
should think about and work with rather
than other kinds of constraints and I
think I've been of the many of the
fundamental constraints around
architecture like the body like site
like economics like material those are
things that have fundamentally are
fundamentally unchanged we just have
much richer ways of engaging them all
right so we can deal with those things
much more in terms of in terms of
process and a sort of holistic
understanding of where they began and
where they end then we have our than we
ever could before and so it allows us to
be more more versatile with the sort of
permutation of those constraints but a
lot of the fundamental things around
design or totally unchanged in fact they
may be amplified with the removal of
other constraints I mean I want to come
in and set the scene we we always talk
about we trying to reach out for is this
kind of complex variegated order and I
think the that we are the different we
want to create environments where many
different audiences and forms of
communication and events in our ears are
kind of coming into close proximity and
are offered up as choices for urban
dwellers to kind of participate
simultaneously and many and fast
sequences that's what I call kind of the
condition of post for is networked
society where each of us needs to be
remain in touch with what everybody else
is doing what else is going on we can't
afford to kind of disappear into
isolated separated corridor cells and
beaver way for ourselves so that means
everything feels close to each other and
then we and the kind of tools were
developing this kind of pliable
malleable primitives which resonate with
each other where deformation means
information where where waves and
ripples and affiliations radiate through
the texture of space this is the kind of
setting the scene and those are the
constraint the complexity of sites the
elements we need to affiliate you with
our buildings all the internal program
differentiations and complexities on how
they recognize each other and
communicate with each other under the
headline everything communities
everything else and I think the for me
it's very important also to see the kind
of reflection on the perceptual
tractability and comprehensibility and
legibility of dense complex scenes and
urban environments and I'm thinking a
lot and my presentation and most of my
presentation are reflecting on the
psychological loss of decomposing
complex scenes into units and units of
interaction what are they what are they
and
and what are the multiple readings which
I can embed in complex environments or
the different audience at different
events filter out and analyze and we
decompose and compose the scene with
respect to at this moment relevant units
of interaction lets me the key problem
and that's I think what what also is the
advantage of that new style where we
work with curvature this continuously
changing courage and gradients where you
can keep more elements in tension and
remain legible and more complex and
information rich environment whereas
with the older modes of composing kind
of stiff elements include glomerata ng
them as disjointed figures you would
ultimately if you build up complexity
you end up with this kind of garbage
spill or a visually-impaired Loy's of
frank fragments so for me that's the key
problem is an task of architectural
articulation is to build up this
complexity to make it objectively
present but make legible perceptually
palpable and navigable and and that's
why I'm very happy with the to have this
this discourse and and we do that
intuitive we're continuously visualizing
and re visualizing the compositions and
and and testing out whether we kind of
find ourselves whether you can isolate
and identify moments at it and even
though though these these become ever
more interest ever more rich and
difficult to perceive environments but I
also believe one thing that we as urban
dwellers are also have a learning
capacity that's why I'm curious are you
saying you can never perceive more than
three four elements if I think of how
we're able to a channel hope and see
rapidly cut television ads in I think
there is also on the subjective level a
capacity to grow with these complex
urban environments that's why I'm a
little skeptical with this kind of sense
that we need to kind of be given kind of
the trees and
water bodies to kind of calm down I
think we need to bear and have the last
four inhabiting a new complexity which
makes it productive okay